sachez est bien à l'image de l'auteur
imposant et puissant un château dressé
au coeur de la vallée de l'indre presque
cachée des regards c'est ici durant le
19e siècle que balzac venait en
villégiature pour écrire et méditer ces
paysages de la touraine profonde lui ont
inspiré des monuments littéraires comme
le lys dans la vallée où le père goriot
près de deux siècles plus tard le musée
local lui rend hommage et celui qu'on
surnommait le géant des lettres a
toujours autant de succès il était
11h45 quelques matinale que fut cette
heure plusieurs femmes qui toutes
avaient voulu se montrer en toilettes
revenait du château non sans retourner
la tête d'un air boudeur comme si elle
se repentait d'être venu trop tard pour
jouir d'un spectacle désirer on a la
chance de lire les textes dans le
paysage dans les paysages
et tout prend sens effectivement et
c'est ce qui surprend agréablement les
visiteurs ce qui leur plaît l'oeuvre
retrouve de la vie à l'intérieur c'est
la rencontre plus intime avec l'auteur
e91 roman balzac était invité à saché
par jean marc gonin notable du cru avec
qui il partageait déjeuner et soirée
entre gens de bonne société ont joué au
whist on savourer des plats et des vins
des plus fins
ce sont tous ces séjours qui sont
retracés avec 116 des références aux
oeuvres car balzac truffer ses écrits de
détails relevés sur place
l'aménagement est sobre et très efficace
entre manuscrits peintures sculptures et
mobilier d'époque on a voulu vraiment à
lui rendre hommage mettre en valeur
cette oeuvre immense la comédie humaine
et parler à la fois de l'auteur est
aussi de l'homme
puisque en découvrant aussi sa vie ici à
saché ses origines on comprend mieux
l'oeuvre expositions randonnées
littéraires lectures en plein air et
dîner sur l'herbe en nocturne au son
d'un discret piano l'été balzacien de
sachets et doux intime et un brin grand
siècle une sorte de comédie humaine des
plus agréables